how about can't appeal man eh look I
know you're all busy and everything man
but you should man you should really
watch these videos dog we trying to help
you out makeshift finding your door
trying to help brothers out try to help
brothers get this going for real
well I'm the one seen this week man that
we thought you know we could like tune
up for y'all and make it better and
whatnot
it's a scene where the two dudes is yeah
yeah you're the food scene where the two
dudes is having a competition see which
one of these my pockets can eat more
food either watch this man y'all got ham
hocks well that's what I want I want to
play the ham hocks deep-fried blackened
and served on a bed of mustard greens
pig feet I want some pig feet and four
pounds of grits Oh ain't no one else
give you a little Dixie cup full of lard
you know like in the same two dudes is
ordered like soul food and whatnot but
you know what it made it funnier fix
yeah if y'all have been ordering dicks
let me eat a rhinoceros dig right now
give me your ass your Park why don't you
give me a full order dinosaur dicks and
then what happened to dick him gasps
right he be like oh
I'm trying to eat all this dick but yeah
but the the poop come out and the
shape of the day
[Laughter]
let's need to make this just smarter
though a little bit smarter raising you
you